[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut ma chérie d'amour mené rentrez
rentrez rentrez à s'installer vous willy
et sa maman sont avec nous on est très
heureux de vous avoir ce soir alors
l'officier d'état civil vient donc de
rejeter la demande de changement de
prénom de lily alors qu'aujourd'hui tout
le monde l'appelle comme ça sa famille
ses proches ses camarades de classe et
même sa maîtresse selon le procureur
pour obtenir le changement de prénom
les parents de lille ils doivent prouver
que leurs enfants entament une
modification irréversible de son corps
de garçon en fille sauf que ce n'est pas
vrai voilà en 2007
depuis 2007 la loi a changé c'est que
ces voix là et la loi permet d'obtenir
ce changement de sexe sans que la
modification physique soit irréversible
c'est pas un cas unique en décembre
dernier la petite stella mi-temps aussi
qu a par exemple obtenu son changement
de nom à l'état civil est déjà merci
lily d'être là merci à toi en temps de
te vois ça fait longtemps qu'on vous
laisse voir tous les deux c'est vrai on
est content de se voir
bon bah on va se revoir maintenant
conserve une fois pas se revoir plein de
fois tu as été déçu de la décision
pourquoi raconte-nous déjà parce que
j'aime moi j'aimerais que tu nous
racontes aussi ton histoire parce que
voilà tu te sentais pas bien dans ce
corps de garçon tu te sentais pas garçon
je continue je j'ai su que j'étais une
fille mary la maternelle s'est pas dit à
maman
tu as dis à personne non tu la garder
pour toi tu n'as même pas dit à tes
copines à tes copains la 10 6 mois avant
nous avant de nous le dira nous six mois
avant l annonce est un copain comme un
copain comme un rappel elle dormait chez
un pote et elle lui a dit mais on a
appris que très tard avec qu'est ce que
tu veux dire lituanie je suis pas un
garçon et une fille et pourquoi quand tu
leur santé ça parce que c'est c'est si
c'est intéressant de savoir comment tu
comment tu l'a ressenti dans c'est pas
facile à expliquer puisque ce que tu as
cuite on est tu l'a ressenti à quel âge
auras 4 5 en trois 3 ans ah ouais et
commencer comment ça se passe comment ça
c'est en france qu'elle était elle s'est
rendue compte de 7-2 de son mal-être
vers 3 ans à l'entrée à l'école d'accord
mais je pense que depuis toujours elle
s'identifier comme une fille en fait non
le voit maintenant à posteriori son
positionnement par rapport à son frère
et sa soeur elle s'est toujours vécu
comme une fille et si à l'école qu'elle
a pris conscience que ce n'était pas
l'équipe à ce genre et comme il fallait
et que ça lui convenait pas du tout les
groupes dans lesquels elle allait donc
elle a commencé chez j jonage elles sont
qu' elle n'était pas sa place rentré
dans une classe de 2e année de
maternelle et demandez-leur les filles
d'un côté des garçons de l'autre n'a pas
un kyste 30 mois tout le monde c'est
intime depuis le plus jeune âge il y met
jamais le souvenir d'avoir été un gars
enfin il il se mettait côté sûreté défi
est donc mais justement comment comment
tu te sens tu es toi tu te sentais pas
bien estelle vous en parler à vous
disais quoi quand elle a commencé à bout
nous paraît quand même la messe elle a
commencé à sentir très très mal l'année
de ses six ans et viendra parler vous a
dit quoi
quand elle m'en a parlé elle m'a dit
qu'elle ne voulait plus de tous ces
attributs masculins
elle n'a pas utilisé ce mot là elle a
dit qu'elle ne voulait plus et voulait
changer son prénom elle voulait plus de
ses cheveux courts militaire et elle
voulait plus de son pénis d'accord
pourquoi pourquoi que celle ben parce
que c'est dur pour une fille d'avoir un
pénis seul chantier pas servir à se
sampler ses doigts pour toi t'es tu
étais pas ta place
ce qui la rendait malheureux c'est ça
c'est le fait de voir grandir sa grande
soeur aussi que s'épanouit comme une
petite jeune fille
et de voir ses cousins et son frère qui
vendre dans la voie où son corps va et
du coup je pense que ce qu'il a mis très
très mal l'année avant cannes ou un
parent c'est justement la difficulté
qu'elle a eu à nous en parler
elle savait pas du tout comment ça
allait être pressée ça et puis et puis
nous on était forcément hyper inquiet
parce qu'une enfants de 6 ou 7 1 qui
explique toutes les façons dont elle
avait pensé pour se tuer face tf1 croit
parce que je sais qu'elle a essayé donc
de penser ça à ton jeune âge tu as
traversé une période de dépression mali
qu'est ce que tu me paraît que je
voulais plus vivre comme ça c'est dur a
évoqué pour elle cette période là parce
que en fait le corps humain il est très
bien fait et la période de latence
qu'elle est en train de le traverser lui
permet d'oublier les mauvais souvenirs
c'est comme ça qu'on se construit tous
en fête en garde le meilleur donc là
elle est en train d'oublier tout
doucement cette phase nous on met des
choses factuelles de côté pour que le
jour où elle le veut s'est replongé elle
puisse avoir son histoire de façon la
plus objective possible mais mais oui du
coup je te rappel de ces soirées là où
c'était dur je restais lendemain près du
lit ça va mieux maintenant lis tu te
sens à ta place la théorie comme vous
avez pris sa christelle ab comme un
soulagement quand on nous laisse entiers
ou las quand on sait quand on sait pas
pourquoi son enfant dit qu'il a envie de
mourir à n'importe quel âge c'est
difficile à certains c'est quand même
très très déstabilisant pour des parents
donc on a vu plein de spécialistes
personnes arrivées à dire d'où venait
son spleen nous a même dit oui c'est une
poétesse elle est née avec un spin
naturel très romantique mais ça nous
aider pas du tout c'était au point où on
se levait la nuit en soit les que mon
mari pour aller voir si mon coeur
battait toujours sur sa poitrine se
soulevait toujours parce que pardon ça
ces mots si c'est difficile
elle nous a fait très peur en fait elle
décrivait tous les soirs les façons
qu'elle était en train de au lieu
d'essayer de s'endormir le penser à
comment elle pouvait mourir
plein de façon hyper précise et efficace
donc c'est hyper douloureux et
angoissant donc on allait la voir la
nuit et heureusement n'avait jamais
passé à l'acte et un soir où elle nous a
dit vraiment que sa vie ne valait pas la
peine d'être vécue comme ça on a essayé
de creuser sur le comme ça comme ça ça
veut dire quoi
et c'est là qu'elle a dit je veux plus
je veux plus de pénis quoi et là bas du
coup c'est un soulagement
si on vous donne la clé de pourquoi elle
va mal elle va mal juste parce qu'elle
n'arrive pas à dire qu'elle veut plus de
son pénis avait dit le vase il exprime
toi donc pas besoin et vous avez dit qu
avec votre mari on a dit ouf ouais on a
dit ouf
et en même temps ça venait répondre à
beaucoup de questionnements en dehors de
ces idées morbides suicidaire lis
toujours une enfant qui a une
sensibilité et un comportement
particulier du coup ça a répondu à nos
questions en fait on s'est dit ah mais
c'est parce que c'est une fille en fait
depuis toujours
lily ma chérie voulez bien en tout cas
on va suivre ton affaire on espère que
ça va s'arranger pour toi le plus
important je le dis c'est qu'aujourd'hui
tu sois heureuse et ait réussi à trouver
pourquoi tu étais dans un mal être et
ses parents ont été formidables et kits
ont suivi et qu'ils ont tout fait pour
que ces heureuses et ça c'est juste de
la paperasse un cd papier et ça va être
vite être réglé je vais te faire un gros
bisou ma chérie d'amour j'étais très
heureux de te voir tu es content d'être
avec moi